wandavision is intriguing for a number
of reasons not the least of which is
that one of its main characters
is currently dead but we know better by
now than to second-guess marvel so
despite the confusion we're eager to see
what wandavision has in store for us
when it hits disney plus
during the company's hall h presentation
at san diego comic con in july of 2019
marvel studios revealed a pretty packed
calendar for 2020 and 21
laying out plans for a whopping 10 new
films and tv series centered around
various characters in the marvel
cinematic universe
originally one division was scheduled to
be the second of seven mcu projects
premiering in 2021
but those plans have been reworked
numerous times since then with multiple
unanticipated delays altering the series
release date
one division initially moved its release
up to late 2020
before being pushed back to 2021 once
again due to the ongoing delays and
disruptions caused by the coronavirus
pandemic while wandavision was
originally intended to be preceded in
phase four by the movie black widow the
disney plus series the falcon and the
winter soldier
and another movie debuting the eternals
team of superheroes the space and time
twisting series will now be the first
entry in the mcu's new chapter
with a premiere date set for january 15
2021
the shake up comes as a result of the
theatrical releases for both black
widow and eternals being delayed to
later in 2021
on the tv side the pandemic related
disruptions caused the falcon and the
winter soldier to experience production
delays that made its planned 2020
release impossible
currently wandavision is the only one of
marvel's upcoming disney plus shows to
have an official release date
originally it was scheduled to lead
right into doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness the follow-up to
2016's doctor strange in which wanda
maximoff is said to play a significant
role
however at least as far as the current
schedule is concerned the two mcu
properties may have their releases
separated by more than a year
with dr strange now being the last of
the phase four films slated to hit
theaters
time is the true enemy of us all time
kills everything
alongside disney's original announcement
that they would be making shows centered
around popular film characters came the
confirmation that elizabeth olsen would
indeed be reprising her mcu role on the
small screen
olson has been playing scarlet witch aka
wanda maximoff since captain america the
winter soldier
when she and her brother quicksilver aka
pietro maximoff were teased in a scene
at the end of the credits
quicksilver was tragically killed at the
end of avengers age of ultron but wanda
went on to join the avengers
while it's debatable which avenger is
the most powerful wanda is a strong
contender for the title and proved to be
one of the team's most effective weapons
against thanos
her abilities in the mcu include
telekinesis telepathy and energy
manipulation
in the comics wanda is an immensely
powerful magic user who can manipulate
chaos magic allowing her to alter
reality while we have yet to see that
ability manifest in the mcu
don't be surprised if wanda vision
delves deeper into the more mystical
side of her abilities
co-starring alongside olson and
wandavision will be her frequent mcu
scene partner paul bettany reprising his
role as the android vision
of course betany's inclusion is a little
surprising since at the end of avengers
infinity war
vision is dead double dead actually so
maybe those reality altering powers of
wandas have a little something to do
with this yet
unexplained development beyond his role
on screen as the vision paul bettany has
actually been with the mcu as a voice
actor from the very beginning
jarvis you up well always however vision
wasn't introduced as a character until
2015's avengers age of ultron when tony
stark's ai butler jarvis was uploaded
into an android body and brought to life
using the mind stone
since then vision has fought alongside
the avengers with formidable powers
including super strength flight
energy blasts and density manipulation
prior to avengers infinity war he also
fell in love with wanda maximoff and the
two were hoping to start a life together
before thanos's arrival put a tragic end
to their plans
vision was murdered by thanos when the
mad titan ripped the stone from his head
in order to complete the infinity
gauntlet
however it would appear that one way or
another vision will be resurrected in
wandavision
captain marvel first introduced us to
monica rambo the school-age daughter of
carol danvers best friend maria
in the comics monica is a grown woman
and a superhero herself
she's gone by several code names
including spectrum and her own version
of captain marvel with monica
technically taking on the name before
carol danvers ever did
while we still don't know whether monica
will be suiting up his spectrum or one
of her other comics aliases we now have
confirmation that an aged up monika will
be entering the mcu as part of the
wandavision cast
the adult monika will be played by tiana
paris while no details have been
revealed about exactly how monica will
factor into wandavision it seems likely
that the events of the series could lead
to her receiving her powers
based on what seemed to be a hint by
paris at san diego comic con
this is a dream to be a marvel
superhero also joining the cast of wand
division are mcu scene stealers kat
dennings and randall park
thenin's appeared in the first two thor
films as darcy lewis
assistant to astrophysicist jane foster
and eric selvik
darcy was last seen at the end of thor
the dark world and wasn't even mentioned
in thor ragnarok making her return in
wandervision a pleasant surprise helping
round out the cast of wand division will
be ant-man and the wasp's former shield
agent jimmy wu
played by randall park like denning's
park's role in his previous mcu film was
largely comedic as the fbi agent tasked
with making sure scott lang stuck to the
restrictions of his house arrest
it's hard to anticipate a scenario that
would lead wanda and vision to cross
paths with wu and darcy
but if there's one thing that's become
abundantly clear about wandavision it's
that it will be embracing the unexpected
rounding out the one division cast as
comedic actress catherine han
playing a character who has only been
officially identified as a nosy neighbor
however while the subtitles on the wand
division trailer refer to her as agnes
many clues point toward han playing the
sorceress agatha harkness
in the comics agatha and the scarlet
witch have a long and complicated
history with agatha acting as wanda's
mentor and teaching her how to use her
magical powers
but it's her interaction with vision in
the one division trailer that may offer
the biggest clue to her role in the
series
am i dead no why would you think that
because you are in tom king's division
comics agatha harkness is in fact dead
and it's her ghost who acts as a
narrator for the series which serves as
a cautionary tale for wanda
since the one division trailer shows han
jumping through time alongside wanda and
vision she may be serving as a similarly
omniscient role here
which teases some dark possibilities for
the seemingly upbeat series
the first and possibly the weirdest of
marvel slate of disney plus shows will
be helmed by television director matt
shakman
best known for his work on the
irreverent fx comedy series it's always
sunny in philadelphia of which he
directed 43 episodes between 2007 and
2017.
however just because shakman has some
serious comedy chops doesn't mean that
wandavision will lack the epic stakes of
the rest of the mcu
over his extensive career shakman has
directed his fair share of serious
dramas
including episodes of the good wife and
fargo and has even dabbled in
superheroes directing episodes of heroes
reborn and the recent amazon original
series the boys
he was also responsible for the game of
thrones season 7 episode the spoils of
war
which featured the visually stunning
loot trained attack sequence
most recently in 2020 shackman was
nominated for an emmy for his work on
the pilot episode of the hulu period
drama the great
loosely based on the life of catherine
the great the series definitely balanced
history comedy high stakes conflict and
emotional drama
given that wand division seems as though
it will be trying to pull off a
similarly challenging juggling act
checkman seems like the ideal director
to balance the power and emotional
backstory of wandavision's characters
with the show's weird and wacky tone
although vision was one of just a few
fallen heroes to not be resurrected at
the end of avengers end game marvel has
confirmed that wand division will be set
after the avengers final battle against
thanos in 2023
but the actual timeline for wandavision
may be a lot more complicated than even
that suggests
with the trailer jumping through
numerous points in time from the 1950s
to today
in 2019 elizabeth olsen revealed that
her new series would be set in the 1950s
although the trailer seems to indicate
that's only partially true
yet for at least its first episode the
series committed to its 1950s aesthetic
filming in front of a live studio
audience with the crew members dressed
in 1950s era clothing
mcu mastermind kevin feige and one
division director matt checkman even met
with dick van dyke while preparing for
the show
asking for any advice the iconic sitcom
star could bestow
his response based on his own experience
was if it couldn't happen in real life
it couldn't happen on the show
but that advice leaves room for some
intriguing applications on a reality
bending marvel show
those words of wisdom will surely be
reinterpreted for a series that seems to
skip across decades as easily as a walk
from room to room
while fans have speculated that wand
division may draw from certain popular
comic book story lines elizabeth olsen
said that wandavision will actually be
pulling from a number of different
comics
so while many aspects of wandavision may
seem familiar to comic fans
viewers probably shouldn't expect the
series to feel particularly beholden to
any individual storyline
vision and scarlet witch have a long
comics history for marvel studios to
pull from for their disney plus series
leaving the door open for a host of
possibilities over the course of their
existence in the comics the characters
have been both heroes and villains and
have gotten married had children
and faced all manner of opposition from
both enemies and allies
while a six-hour series probably doesn't
leave enough time for all of that
at least the writers of wandavision have
no shortage of material from which to
draw inspiration
originally scheduled to release in the
spring of 2021 wandavision's six-episode
run was intended to end just as doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
swept into theaters that may
however both have since been jostled
around on marvel's calendar
and wandavision will now be bowing on
disney plus in january 2021
while the doctor strange sequel won't
hit theaters until march 25th
2022 still despite the scheduling
shake-up the two tales are likely to be
closely linked
elizabeth olsen has been confirmed as a
co-lead of the dr strange sequel
and kevin feige teased that the events
of juan division will lead wanda right
to stephen strange's doorstep
allow me to help you there are a number
of reasons why wanda may ultimately need
assistance from the master of the mystic
arts
given the title of the second doctor
strange film it seems likely that the
events of wandervision will somehow
contribute to the multiverse of madness
that doctor strange will be dealing with
in his second solo outing
whether scarlet witch and doctor strange
wind up as allies or opponents remains
to be seen
but it's safe to assume that wanda and
vision's adventures in wand division are
going to have some unforeseen
and possibly magical consequences even
after playing a pivotal role in four
films wanda maximoff has yet to be
called scarlet witch out loud in the mcu
the closest anyone has come to utter in
her code name was in avengers age of
ultron when tony stark was trying to
calm down
hulk that little witch is messing with
your mind
although she goes by both names
interchangeably in the comics wanda has
always been referred to by her given
name on screen
however if elizabeth olsen's comments at
san diego comic con in 2019 are any
indication she will finally receive her
official code name in wandavision
along with an explanation for exactly
why she goes by that moniker
chances are it has something to do with
her immense potentially reality shifting
magic like powers
and the color of the energy she
manipulates with her hands but even
though the origin of her code name seems
rather obvious it will still be nice to
get explicit confirmation of her name
and its meaning within the mcu
i don't even know who you are you will
frequently touted as the mcu's first
sitcom the first trailers for wand
division have revealed that not only
will the disney plus series be heading
into uncharted marvel territory but it
will be paying homage to a number of
familiar titles in the process
scattered amongst the brief glimpses of
the show we've seen so far have been
what appears to be nods to a number of
sitcoms classics
including bewitched the brady bunch
roseanne family ties
i love lucy and of course the dick van
dyke show what it all means is more
mysterious than ever
but one thing is for certain paul
bettany was definitely not overstating
things when he described the show as
bunkers the brief teaser for wand
division shown during the 2020 super
bowl featured a short shot of wanda and
vision looking down at two cribs then
jumping as two pacifiers popped up into
the frame
the full trailer seems to confirm that
these are indeed wanda and vision's twin
sons
billy and tommy whose introduction in
wandavision could have major
repercussions not just for rwanda and
vision themselves but for the rest of
the mcu as a whole
of course comics fans know that billy
and tommy play a huge role in multiple
comic story lines
their disappearance leads to the popular
avengers disassembled and house of m
storylines both of which are significant
comics events with lasting repercussions
if any of these story lines are brought
into the mcu the effects could be huge
in the comics billy and tommy also grow
up to become two of the founding members
of the young avengers team
while their inclusion in wan division
may not seem significant yet
introducing the twins leaves the door
open for some pretty major developments
in the future
as soon as it was announced that wand
division would have a 1950s aesthetic
some fans began speculating that it may
adapt parts of tom king's run of comics
for the vision which ran for 12 issues
beginning in 2015.
the vision followed an entirely
synthetic family vision had created for
himself
consisting of his wife virginia and
their children vin and viv
the comics theme centered around family
normality and what it means to be truly
human
as a family of synthetics the visions
are constantly in search of a better
understanding of life
driven by their desire to be seen as
normal although the specifics would need
to change for wandavision it's easy to
see how these themes of humanity and
family would fit into a series about the
mcu versions of wanda and vision
after all the last time these two
characters were together and happy in
the mcu they were trying to figure out a
way to share in a normal
life together given their extraordinary
abilities and circumstances
in another comic storyline after wanda's
children die she alters the reality of
earth creating a new world in which they
are alive
this new reality led to the highly
acclaimed house of m comics event an
alternate reality arc created out of
wanda's grief and magic
that arc led into the less well-received
decimation storyline in which wanda
strips all mutants of their powers
house of m has long been popular among
comics fans and has even been mentioned
by mcu writers christopher marcus and
stephen mcfeely as a storyline they
considered adapting for inclusion in
either infinity war or end game
the mcu version of wanda doesn't have
children yet although the wan division
trailer hints that that may soon
change but her grief over the loss of
vision could work as a setup for a
similar story
a house of m like premise could explain
not only vision's resurrection and
wonder vision but also the incongruous
time periods
if wanda is altering reality maybe she
keeps reimagining what reality looks
like while the lack of mutants in the
mcu means significant liberties would
need to be taken with any sort of house
of m adaptation
all the other pieces are in place for a
grief fueled story in which wanda alters
the world to bring back someone she
loves
elizabeth olsen has been vocal about her
excitement for her disney plus series
telling the audience at marvel's
comic-con presentation
we're gonna go deep we're gonna have
lots of surprises
and we're gonna finally understand wanda
maxim off as the scarlet witch
wanda has been described as weird in the
mcu before back when agent maria hill
was first bringing captain america up to
speed on wanda and her brother's
superpowers
he's got increased metabolism and
improved thermal homeostasis
her thing is neuroelectric interfacing
telekinesis mental manipulation
he's fast and she's weird however we
expect that when olson said the series
would be weird she wasn't simply
referring to her existing powers but
something brand new and bizarre that
we've never seen before in the mcu
kevin feige backed up olson's promises
telling the audience
wait until you see this show it's unlike
anything we've done before and as for
the vision himself
paul bettany thinks audiences are in for
a unique treat with wandavision
it's so funny and it's just ends up
being this huge
epic it's the the writing so
extraordinary so while we may still not
know exactly what to expect from the
weird world of wanda vision
after seeing the excitement of everyone
involved we're sure will blow our minds
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you